All right,
we're live.
First of all,
thank you very much for coming.
I really appreciate it.
Well,
if I get the hell man,
man,
looking forward to it for a long time.
I am as well.
I enjoyed our conversation in New York City two years ago now.
Right?
It was a fun time and um,
I've been a big fan of your work for a long time before that and I find you a
fascinating character and I'm glad you.
I mean you got up early this morning,
English time.
It's 8:00 here in Los Angeles,
so this is like,
what do you like eight hours ahead of us?
So we're talking to a,
to even out for awhile fella.
This is not good for life expectancy,
right?
This is certainly true.
People.
Let's play this out.
I think another thing that I do that are probably not good for me,
that's the one,
and I'll get enough sleep.
Don't get enough sleep.
And you like the booze fella that.
Well that may be good for me.
You never know.
Really moderation in moderation.
Yeah.
While we're drinking it right now,
a little Jack Daniels,
is that supposed to be good for colds?
Does that.
A man is working for me.
Okay.
It does work for you.
Really.
It helps you.
It certainly does whatever makes you feel better.
Um,
you're involved at the.
For folks who don't know Aubrey de Grey,
you're a researcher at Cambridge.
You were involved.
Very much so in the forefront of anti aging life extension.
As far as medical science is concerned,
you're at the forefront of this.
So actually,
first of all,
correct.
One thing,
I haven't been affiliated with the University of Cambridge for a very long time
now.
How long has it been?
Fucking wikipedia tells assholes.
Two thousand six or something like that.
Yeah,
I mean basically the same as we were able to bring enough funding to be able to
pay me a full time salary.
It made most sense for me to know actually we're doing something else to pay the
bill.
So what is your organization now?
So sensory fetched foundation where if I a one C,
three public charity in mountain view,
California and we,
uh,
a level of roughly $5,000,000 per year in terms of our budget,
so we're still really pretty small,
but I think we spend it pretty well.
And for folks who said what's wrong with his voice,
he's suffering from a bit of a cold right now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's why he's drinking the whiskey.
I don't know how it works that way.
What,
what is,
what's exciting right now in terms of like medical research when it comes to
life extension,
like what are,
what are the exciting areas to you're pursuing?
Perhaps the most exciting thing is that no one exciting thing they really
important thing to understand about medical research into aging is to start out
from remembering that aging is not just one phenomenon.
It's a collection,
a network of interacting phenomena,
and the way that it's going to be effectively tackled by medicine in the
fullness of time is by a divide and conquer strategy.
A panel of interventions,
all of which need to work with me really well in order for the whole nfs to
actually work,
um,
to an appreciable degree in terms of Perth Berman,
devel health.
So from my point of view,
I'm working at the coalface,
so to speak.
It's a fantastic thing that,
you know,
there's always something every week there's something that's got a new
breakthrough here in that.
But of course the breakthroughs are often very technical.
There are often things that only specialists would understand that they actually
were breakthroughs.
They're not like,
you know,
we haven't doubled the mice,
the lifespan of mice in the past week,
for example.
Nevertheless,
that's fine.
You know,
I mean,
that's how pioneering technology has always developed and the people that do
need to understand,
in other words,
the people who are doing the research and who need to know about each other's
results in order to know what experiment to do next.
You know that that community obviously is sufficiently cohesive that these
pieces of information are distributed.
I obviously play a large part in doing that as well as in actually overseeing
the research that the foundation does.
So,
um,
you know,
coming back to my original statement,
there's no one answer,
um,
but they,
that's a very good point because is there a lot of cooperation between the
various different individuals all throughout the world are working on these life
extension technologies and life extension medical science.
So that's actually a totally different question to which the answer is
depressingly different.
Um,
the failed,
the individual failed that I think all need to be developed to a reasonable
degree of efficacy in order to actually give the overall result that individual
failed a nightly cohesive and people talk to each other within the field.
But between the failed,
it's a very different matter.
One of the things that I've had to do,
everything that I started out in this area,
and certainly over the past,
let's say 10 or 12 years,
I've had to actively bring these people together,
the far too much balkanization building up of silos and of,
you know,
unnecessary barriers between field that somehow don't think that they're
relevant to each other.
And this happens not in any way.
I'm not blaming the scientists for that because it happens rarely as a result of
the vagaries of funding.
The fact that nobody's got enough money and therefore in order to get whatever
they can,
they've got to focus on the things that are already known to be good at.
It works extraordinarily strongly against the um,
uh,
the portability of cross disciplinary work and also against high risk,
high gain work.
And it really massively flow science and technology down.
So it's a tragedy and everyone kind of knows it,
but nobody really knows what to do about it.
It's not any one person's interests to do anything about it.
So the whole system is perpetuated.
So is it one of those situations where you have like various pharmaceutical
companies or what have you,
standing on the outside looking in,
waiting for something to be something that they could
put their chips on something where they can hedge their bets and say,
okay,
this is a,
this is a promising little piece of research here.
Now we'll start to gamble on this being profitable down the line because for
medication especially to be ultimately profitable is there's a huge period of
testing and research and ultimately can cost millions and millions of dollars
before you could ever even find out the efficacy of a product.
That's exactly right.
And again,
if not quite the same thing as I was thinking about it,
but it's related when I was talking about earlier was really with respect to
academia per se,
with respect to people who rely on government funding to get worked on the
pharmaceutical industry or more generally the medical industry have a different
perspective,
but it kind of has the same kind of problem.
Um,
medicine is tricky to do and everyone wants to keep it as simple as possible,
which means the inherent bias against,
um,
against cross disciplinary work,
against a divide and conquer strategy that involved doing more than one thing at
the same time to the same person,
but ultimately we're going to have to bite that bullet and there are smart
people in the pharmaceutical and medical industry just as there are in academia
and everyone kind of getting used to this.
It's just that it's a very difficult thing for anyone to be the first group,
the first company,
the first place,
first referred group to actually do it.
Kind of got to be a collective shift of mindset.
I kind of sea change in the culture of how all this is done.
So is this something that's being actively pursued all over the world?
Are there pockets of intellectuals that are working on this or
all over the world,
but yet only pockets.
I'm afraid at this point there is still an enormous tendency,
enormously productive tendency to retreat into doing what just makes money
quickly and what get papers published quickly irrespective of whether it's Gals,
in other words,
whether it leads to significant progress in the longer term.
So,
uh,
the biggest thing that I always point to if they absolutely biologically
inaccurate and damaging idea that the diseases of old age or in farm fence
distinct from aging itself,
it's complete nonsense that leaves about eight.
Anything that causes people who were born a long time ago to be fair,
but it doesn't tend to affect people who are in early adulthood.
Those things are that way because they are side effect of being alive.
They are side effects of having been alive and accumulating damage for a long
time in the body.
And that is the only thing that one can fire the definition of aging itself to.
So one should not be dividing these two things and saying the things that
disease and this other thing,
if not,
we shouldn't be doing that.
And if we doing that,
then we've got a chance of actually understanding how to attack the this network
of interacting l health issues that affect the elderly in a manner that really
works.
We will stop trying to be over optimistic about these things that we choose to
call to.
They've learned over pessimistic about the things that we don't and we'll start
to realize that all of them together can be tackled.
So you're looking at aging itself as a type of a disease.
I would actually go the other way.
I would say that the right thing to do is not to look at the local diseases of
old age diseases because of course there is a huge distinction between the,
between things that are side effect of being alive in the first place,
on the one hand and infections,
infections or what the word disease should be restricted to infections and
congenital diseases that we say,
um,
infections can be actually eliminated from the body that can be cured by bashing
away at the symptoms and eliminating the infectious itunes.
Now,
if you try to do that with something that's a side effect of being alive,
you're obviously not going to succeed unless you like go as far as eliminating
being alive,
which you'd rather defeat the object.
Right.
So,
um,
so you know,
that's the,
that's the conceptual thing that people think that something like outside of or
atherosclerosis or cancer is basically just not all that different from
tuberculosis complete bullshit.
And that fundamental conceptual error causes enormous amount of money to be
spent in the wrong way against the diseases of old age in ways that will only
ever make a very minimal impact on the disease.
So is that,
that there's sort of a resignation,
that Alzheimer's is just a side effect of old age,
that there's nothing they can do about.
Ah,
well no,
no,
the is not a resignation.
People say it's a disease,
therefore we should not on your part.
But I mean that's the problem that people think they can cure it in isolation.
They think,
oh,
it's people get old,
but let's kill it.
So what you're saying is what we have to cure is the getting old part.
That's right.
Okay.
What are,
what's.
What do you think will be the method ultimately,
and obviously there's a bunch of different ideas.
What do you think will be the method ultimately that we move into that
direction?
It's been very clear to me for at least 15 years now that the way to do this is
damage repair,
that we must develop a panel of intervention,
the panel of therapies which go in and restore the molecular and cellular
structure and composition of the body of an elderly person.
To her it was more or less in early adulthood,
so that means things like putting cells back when the body is having fellows
dying and not being not being automatically replaced by cell division.
It means taking sales away when cells are dividing,
when they're not supposed to or when they're not dying,
when they are supposed to.
It means cleaning out molecular waste products if they're accumulating because
they saw the body doesn't know how to get rid of them,
doesn't know how to break them down or to excavate them.
You know,
pretty basic things really,
but it turns out that even thinking in that it sounds like a very simplistic
way.
It's a very robust framework for actually identifying what needs to be fixed and
how to fix it.
Do you think that diet,
it all plays a part in this or do you recommend a specific diet to people to
enhance their their body's ability to repair itself?
I don't really do that first for two reasons.
First of all,
with regard to data and a more generally lifestyle,
anything that people can do today,
I definitely take the view that there are plenty of other people who know more
about the me and the four.
If I also became an expert in this area,
I really wouldn't be making as much difference as I am making by spending my
time in this other way.
Second thing is that,
and this is rather depressing,
but it's rather an important thing to mention that as far as we can tell,
the overwhelming evidence is that none of these things make very much difference
to most people.
It feel an unlucky person.
If you're someone who drew the short Straw and you are aging unusually rapidly,
then it's a bit different.
Um,
especially if you're aging unusually rapidly,
only in one particular way or one or two ways.
Then maybe there are supplements or dietary or lifestyle regimen that will
substantially normalize your rate of aging and that's obviously a good thing,
but for those of us who are already average,
especially for those of us who are already doing better than average,
that's not the case.
The evidence seems to be that these interventions simply don't give you anymore.
The body is already as well tuned as it can be subject only to the development
of much more sophisticated interventions of the thought that sensory research
foundation is working on.
So the things like getting good sleep,
getting good diet,
they're really essentially only one
go so far.
There are only going to go very familial out.
That's right.
So you'll have a.
we'll live an extra 10 years or sometimes even 10.
I think an overstatement,
I think we're talking like more like one or two if you're lucky.
One or two.
So he pulls it up.
Folks,
here's a,
here's a good illustration of this.
People often around the rest of the world,
you know,
people laugh at the Ufa a lot for it,
for the fact that even though it spans a huge amount of medical care far more
ahead than any other country.
Nevertheless,
if you look at longevity,
uh,
the USA is way down the leg table.
It's like number 45 or something like that.
Ridiculous.
People say,
well,
this is just so you know,
that
that money doesn't buy health or something.
But actually a much more important message comes if you look at the real
numbers,
not just the league table,
it's something I'd like to ask you,
just if you know that.
What do you think the difference is between the life expectancy of people in the
USA and the life expectancy of people in Japan?
The longest live country in the world?
I would say the life expectancy,
the United States is probably a good average is probably in your sixties where I
would say Japan is probably in your seventies,
so I'll give you a number.
Sixty four,
78.
How about that?
You say you're going to say 14 years.
Yes.
Four years.
Four full full.
It's not much.
That's right.
That's my point.
And the for the last four,
really,
you can have them.
Well,
of course the left foil you can.
It's the same in Japan.
A long time if to stay healthy long time first and then the.
The,
the period of decline is typically about fame.
However long the period of good health was beforehand.
So in all these factors that people look to to enhance like,
you know,
surround yourself with loved ones,
have a good community,
but do something that you enjoy doing it when they're talking.
They're really only talking about a very small amount of time
anyway.
The reason I spent so much time emphasizing this and making sure that people
understand it is because if people don't understand,
if people think well,
they can do a great deal to post the oral health just by doing things that they
can do already,
then they're going to be correspondingly less enthusiastic,
less committed to figuring out and helping and hastening the development of
things that we can't do already.
Of course,
the sort of stuff that I'm working on,
it's really because the impact of things that we can do today so small that it
becomes urgent to develop new things.
What do you think will be the method for repairing damage?
I mean how?
How will that find itself in our lives?
There are many different types of debt and the only reason why it was possible
for me to come up with a really solid,
robust clinical research program was because 15 years ago I was able to identify
a way to classify.
They've many types of damage into a much more manageable number of categories.
Just seven categories within the law.
Within each category there is just one generic intervention which may differ in
detail from one example within the category to another,
but early in detail.
So basically we're talking about and seven different types of repair.
So for illustration,
let me just talk about when I tell them I'm one type of damages,
loss of cells,
cells dying and not being automatically replaced by the division of other cells.
That basically the reason why we get Parkinson's disease.
That's probably the best example of it.
Most obvious example,
I'm now in Parkinson's disease.
What happens is there's just one part of the brain called the substantia Nigra
in which there are a special type of neuron called dopaminergic neurons.
These neurons die much more rapidly than neurons in most parts of the brain,
and sure enough eventually they have enough of them now and most of us,
you've already lost about 20 percent of guys near by old age,
but some people live a little bit faster and then maybe a last 70 or 80 percent
intellegence.
Those are the people that got Parkinson's disease,
so then they asked what is the damage repair?
The onset,
it's actually really clear and well known in this case,
namely stem cell therapy.
That's what stem cell therapy is you,
but excuse me,
you put cells into the body that are prepared in advance,
so to speak.
They're set up so that they will have the tendency to divide and transform into
replacements for the cells that the body was not replacing lights out.
So you restore the number of cells in the tissue.
Does she started working again?
You've fixed the disease and about 20 years ago people started trying this
because people realize this didn't really work too well back that and it worked
occasionally,
but the basic problem was we didn't know enough about how to manipulate stem
cells before injecting them into the body.
Now we know a lot,
lot more and there are new stem cell trials for Parkinson's disease starting up
now,
which people are really optimistic about it.
I think there's a very good chance,
I would say even a 50 slash 50 chance that we will be able to say in as little
as 10 years from now,
the Parkinson's disease has genuinely been cured with them.
South therapy.
Wow.
That is very promising.
That's incredible.
Ten years.
That's a relatively short amount of time.
Unless your.
It is 74.
Yeah,
right.
It a short amount of time.
A lot of the therapies that we think also need to be developed to address other
part of aging.
I think harder than that and I think we could be talking about 20 or 25 years
and even then we're only talking about a 50 slash 50.
A probability of getting there for anything that's more than a few years away.
It's obviously extremely speculative.
If we're talking about timeframes,
I think we have a responsibility to give her a bath,
get to the general public because the general public's bath guest is going to be
a lot worth.
Right.
And you've got to know,
you've got to have some kind of idea of how close something in order to
understand how much to agitate to make it happen faster,
you know,
mean a thousand years away.
It's not going to be a priority to make it only 990 years away.
Right.
Um,
so that's,
that's a big part of why we to talk about these timeframes.
But yes,
I mean I think there's at least a 10 percent chance that we won't get there for
a hundred years.
Wow.
That's no big deal,
right?
Because 50 percent challenge is quite enough to be worth fighting for.
Most.
Certainly.
You and I met at the global two,
what
is it?
20,
45 initiative event in New York City,
which is a group of sort of a,
a group of two different groups of people.
There's people that are concerned with biological aging,
which is your group medical,
biological aging,
and these people that some folks classify as a Psi Phi dreamers.
That belief you're going to be able to download your consciousness into a robot
and bypass the whole biological process in the first place and that all this
work about repair,
it's only going to be a moot point because we're going to get to a point where
we're going to develop a body that's far superior to the biological body that
we're born with and will simply,
in part our consciousness into that.
Do you give any credence to that?
Do you do dabble in that or do you just concentrate on what you're doing?
I have a very open mind about these things.
I'm not at all fun of people talking about things that are clearly impossible,
but very often when I'm thinking initially looked clearly impossible look left,
you understand that it might actually already definitely really difficult,
or this could be an example.
Uploading is the idea of moving world consciousness to a difference.
Hardware,
you know,
it's not completely clear that it can't be done.
The May and the end be reasons why it totally can't be done,
but I think all that really matters now is that we can say that it's very
difficult.
I think that,
yeah,
I would certainly say in fact that
I bet serious money that the problem with aging will be decisively solved by a
biomedical approach of the thought that we're aware pursuing well before it gets
sold by an uploading a pro,
but here's the thing,
like a central technologist,
I know I might be wrong and therefore I'm delighted that there are people
working in these other areas so further,
if they their work turned out to be easier than I think it hit and my work turns
out to be harder,
that and they get their first,
then there'll be saving lives that I couldn't save.
That works for me.
Now,
there's a philosophical debate here,
a philosophical conversation,
and that conversation is,
why would you want to continue?
How long do you truly want to live?
Do you want to live to be a thousand?
Do you want to live to be 100,000 years and will that be an issue as well?
As far as national,
our national natural resources go.
I mean,
are we already overpopulated?
Are we already putting a tremendous burden on the natural resources of this
planet that will be accentuated by a thousand year old people just running
around having babies when they're 900 years old.
So I'm going to hold for that question in two very separate parts.
First we're going to talk about the so called philosophical issue of how long
one would want to live.
I find that quite remarkable that people worry about this simply because it's
not the way that people actually think about anything else.
Let's remember that the longevity aspect of all of this work is a side effect.
I don't work on longevity.
I don't.
I certainly don't work on immortality the way you might think if you read the
papers.
I just work on health.
I'm just interested in stopping people from getting sick when they get older.
Now if you think about it,
all medicine is like that.
All medicine involves stopping people from getting sick or fixing them up if
they are fake and old medicine has a side effect that people live longer than
they otherwise would have done.
So the only real difference between the work that sensory research foundation
does and the work that everything everyone else in medical research does is a
difference of degree.
The fact that the longevity side effect of our work may be substantially greater
than the longevity side effect that we're familiar with.
It's still a side effect.
So if we come to the question of how well I might want to live,
you know,
just like any,
even a meaningful question to me,
it's like saying,
what time would you like to go to the toilet next Sunday?
You know,
we know that that's a dumb thing to have an opinion about it.
A dumb thing to have an opinion about because we know we're going to have more
information on the topic near at the time and we're going to be able to act on
the information and it's the same deal.
You know,
nobody makes decisions on the basis of how long ago they were bought.
People increasingly make decisions as they get older on the basis of how long
they think they've got to live,
but that's because the amount of time they think they've got to live with going
down,
which won't be going down anymore.
If you've got an arbitrary amount of time behind you earn other arbitrary amount
of time ahead of you,
your decision making is going to be based on more short term considerations,
you know,
like peer pressure.
And so,
you know,
as I point out,
when people ask me these things oftentimes say,
okay,
take yourself back to the first time you got laid.
Oh yeah.
Alright.
Now think about what you were thinking at the time.
Were you thinking,
Oh my God,
I have to get this person into bed right now because I've only got another 60
years to live.
So what?
I mean it's just ridiculous.
Okay,
so then I want to come to like the second half of your question,
which was the business about overpopulation and such.
Like this is I again,
I,
I recall somewhat at the idea that the.
He said for philosophical question to me it's a psychological question and
that's not the same at all,
but without getting into semantics,
what is the answer?
I have a three level onset and this applies to all of the questions were might
arrays with regard to the problems that might hypothetically be created as a
consequences of solving the problem we've got today.
The problem of writing,
right?
So first thing is specific answers.
Just let look at the actual scenario closely rather than a knee jerk reaction
and say,
is the problem actually let you to occur at all?
Now,
in the case of of the population,
what we have to ask ourselves,
okay,
how rapidly would the population actually increase in the context of eliminating
death from aging and how badly with that matter?
At the moment,
we've already got an overpopulation problem.
We've got too many people on the planet.
We've got global warming and stuff.
Well,
why do we have global warming?
It's not because we have 7 billion people.
It's because we have 7 billion people,
all of whom are burning a lot of carbon and that's not going to be true for very
long.
As we ramp up solar energy and we invent nuclear fusion and so on,
you know the is going to be in the relatively near future a situation where we
increase the carrying capacity of the planet a lot by these technologies that
mean that we can have more people with less environmental impact.
It's very likely that that kind of trajectory,
and of course I'm not only talking about global warming here and talking about
all other types of pollution that we engage in,
that kind of technology will out run any changes that may happen in terms of
demography,
so that's the first level.
The second level answer is perhaps more important to kind of general while
applies across the board,
whether it's other population you're worried about or boredom or dictators
living forever or how will we pay the pensions or any of the standard digit
reactions.
The answer is how bad could it be?
Let's have a sense of proportion about this.
How bad could the problems be?
As a
relative to the severity of the problem we have today and also ones that
question,
we have to remind ourselves exactly what is the severity of the problem we have
today,
how many people die of aging every day?
The answer is 100,000 dollars and of course most of them don't just die.
They die after a long period of disease and debilitation and decrepitude a
decline and dependency in general misery.
So there is no question that aging is responsible for the vast majority of human
suffering in the world today.
Not even if we don't even have to restrict ourselves to the industrialized
world.
The overall,
I was asking you about life expectancy earlier,
so saying like,
you know,
a four year difference between the US and Japan.
Turns out there's only 10 years difference between the world as a whole and
Japan.
Is that amazing or what?
That's pretty amazing.
So worst case scenario and best case scenarios,
only 10 years.
Well not worse case average case.
Real worse than they are down in the forties or fifties.
But worst case as far as global mean,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
so I mean,
what we're saying here is aging,
it's undoubtedly the world's worst problem right now has been for a long time
and we have to ask,
you know,
even supposing,
but we ended up in a situation where population was going to be a problem
because we hadn't invented technologies fix that to increase the carrying
capacity of the planet quite as rapidly as we needed to.
So we were faced with this rather irritating feature of having to have fewer
children than we would like in order to make room for all the elderly herstal
healthy and not dying.
How bad is that?
Seems to me it's hard.
It's hard to make a case that the right thing to do would be to let the people
age and die rather than to your okay.
And the third level of answer is perhaps the most decisive of all,
some level of.
I said,
well,
even if you've convinced yourself that these problems are going to happen,
and even if you also convinced yourself that these problems are going to be so
bad that they might outweigh the problem that we're solving.
The question is who used to say who should actually be making the decision as to
whether the therapy,
the years.
The answer clearly is humanity of the future rather than humanity of the
precedent.
If we say to ourselves,
Oh dear,
oh dear,
you know the population,
whatever,
let's not go there and we thereby delay the development of these therapies that
what we would be doing is denying humanity of the future,
the option whether to use the therapy based on the information that it had
available to us about,
you know,
available technology that will ever.
What if we develop these things as fast as possible,
then humanity of the dads get the choice.
Now I do not want to be someone who is helping to condemn a cohort of the future
to an unnecessarily painful and unnecessarily early death.
Just because I thought I knew better than that.
Innovation and advancement seems to be a fundamental part of human society and
civilization.
It just seems to be something that we do no matter where you go to someone who
was always trying to improve upon everything.
When you have medical science,
it only stands to reason that that too would try to improve and advance and life
expectancy of,
of course,
the way you describe it,
the way you did with that being the number one problem physically,
health wise in our world,
that's going to be a huge issue.
It's going to be a huge issue that we're going to try to solve.
It's a fundamental part of being a human being.
I very much like the way you said that.
I think that the right way to explain the fallacy of,
um,
we could leave aging alone because natural,
which some people say,
some people say,
well,
you know,
aging is not like a disease.
They have them through everything.
It's basically natural.
We shouldn't touch it.
And you're absolutely right.
You said it perfectly.
The way I would say is like,
it would be unnatural for us to,
to,
to say,
oh dear,
let's leave it alone.
Even though it's horrible.
It was natural for the human for humanity is to see what's natural and we don't
like,
and to fix it.
Well,
there's that existential angst that people tend to wallow in and what's the
point,
what's it's all going to end some day,
what's the big deal?
And there's,
you know,
many groups have been many different schools of thought when it comes to that.
Some people just think that's nonsense,
enjoyed the moment,
live in the moment,
live,
live today.
Don't worry about the fee,
but there's a lot of people who don't subscribe to that,
who really do get depressed when they worried about their inevitable demise.
When you come across,
when you come around and say,
hey,
we are developing new technologies that are gonna,
allow you to live within this lifetime.
We're going to meet the first person who lives to be a thousand years.
They're like,
well great.
A thousand years of suffering an existential angst.
They don't want it and that's where it's a philosophical question really because
it's a matter of how do you approach everyday,
how do you.
How do you approach this experience?
Do you look at this experience?
Like you said,
the moment you get laid,
go,
Geez,
I got to get her into bed because I only have 60 years left,
or do you look at this experience saying,
while this is going on,
there are a million wonderful things to enjoy about this life,
and on top of that,
it seems to me that as time goes on,
we're getting far better with this whole civilization thing and one of the
things that I think would benefit us more than anything possible would be if we
could have people that could be alive and healthy and live for 500 years.
I imagine that type of wisdom that they could impart on the rest of us imagined
the life lessons that you would get from a few centuries of mistakes and
corrections and lessons and and and information that you've absorbed.
We could transform society and culture,
World Society,
not National Society,
not local society,
but world society in a radical way.
Just with the wisdom that we would all be able to share.
I think there was a lot of truth in that.
Absolutely.
I think,
you know,
maybe you could argue that the fact that we have culture,
that we can write things down and fell and maybe that doesn't matter so much
that individuals could be around the white elephant for whatever.
But in practical terms,
it does matter.
I think it's got forgotten when the people who came of with them a lot around
anymore and things got rediscovered.
Twentieth,
30th lights,
right through other rather ridiculous the refill for a related point which I
think is worth bringing up at the,
uh,
the state with regard to the,
um,
uh,
the,
the value of,
of living a long time and the value of all of the perceived value of living a
long time,
which is that at the moment,
the people who feel well life not worth living,
flavor or whatever are actually the same people who have a lot of trouble
understanding why the life worth living for 50 years.
You know,
the people that spend their time essentially living their life in front of the
television,
they difficulty here is simply a lack of education.
The fact that most people in today's world do not have the training to be able
to understand how to get the most out of life,
who do they do have good education,
good understanding of how to get the most out of life.
We always have a massive backlog.
I've probably got a thousand years of backlog already.
Other thing that I'd like to have done,
you know,
I've found that I liked to have seen books.
I'd like to ride,
play for elect of God.
People don't like to have matt,
and by the time I'm through that,
I'm certain I'm going to have at least another 10,000 years of backlog.
Right?
So,
um,
so,
you know,
I mean,
all we need really is to educate people better.
That's an interesting way to put it.
Educate.
Uh,
I,
I tend to agree with you,
but I think that for a lot of people it tends to be an issue of mental health.
Uh,
there's certain people that suffer from depression or struggle with depression
and life itself becomes very difficult for them to endure.
Okay.
I will stop you there.
Please come.
Because the thing I think we need to understand the spectrum where there are
obviously some people who are extremely depressed.
I have a friend actually in the UK who is clinically depressed right now about
the problem of aging.
Her parents are in a bad way.
There is a plan and it's really going to.
And um,
you know,
that's an extreme example.
If we talk about the just Malays know the end,
we,
that,
uh,
that I think is a much milder version of the same thing.
Then I will accept what you say that this is quite common,
but I would also say that it's part of what I was talking about,
lack of training,
lack of,
lack of exposure to the opportunities that life has to offer.
A lack of understanding of how to actually seek out those opportunities.
So I don't think it's such a hard thing to eliminate
because I don't agree with you that it's education because I know some very
educated people that struggle with depression and I think a lot of it has to do
with physical health that the,
the meat wagon that you're carrying around,
that you're trudging through life with.
If it's burdensome,
if it's causing you issues,
if you don't take care of it,
if you eat poorly,
if you smoke cigarettes,
if you,
you tend to overindulge and alcohol and it leaves your liver constantly
processing state and you're just a mess.
Like those people tend to have a dollar experience and perhaps a,
a more burdensome experience.
Sure.
I just,
it's like the tail of the curve.
People that badly like that paypal.
And if we don't get the lodge end of the population in the thick end of the
wedge,
then we're talking about a model,
the phenomenon.
But actually remind me of another thing that,
um,
you know,
the is at the moment a very strong tendency in society say when exposed to the
ideas about the possibility of bringing education to control.
And consequently living under strong tendency to think,
oh my God,
the law,
the quality of that life will be put advance because people have this sense in
their head that quality and quantity,
I inherently opposed to each other.
The more quantity you have,
the left quality you're bound to have.
And of course that makes sense in today's world in a way because by large to the
either a lot of things we like to do that are bad for it will shorten their
lives by,
you know,
whether it's smoking or whatever.
Um,
but that's not going to be true in a scenario in a world in which we have
therapists that can actually address these various types of damage and repair
them in those situations.
If you think they gotta be on the same side of the fence,
quality is going to be the thing that confers quantity.
So you imagine a world where cigarettes are being consequential.
You be smoking cigarettes just pop in some sort of repair pill and Bam,
no more Marlboro cancer.
Well basically,
yeah,
I mean I don't like to point that out too heavily because of course it's not
true yet,
so thank you on it.
Well,
right.
That's right.
I mean we don't know how long the therapy they're going to take to come along
and they bat in order to maintain your chances of to maximize your chances of
actually being around in time to benefit from the therapy they actually live
with healthy lifestyle.
You can't at the moment.
I mean I were talking earlier about maybe you'll only get a year or two,
but that might be the key area too,
right?
It might be the key year or two that brings us to the next thousand.
Exactly.
You said that stem cells within a decade,
you believe there's a large possibility that it could cure Parkinson's,
these other things that may be 50 slash 50 and 25 years.
Like what are they like what,
what are the big ones that you're excited about?
Well,
so most of what we work on,
it sounds very first foundation.
If they thought things,
we actually do basically no stem cell therapy work and that family,
because so many other people are doing and it's understood as a very plausible
and very exciting approach to treating a number of different conditions,
not restricted,
of course do age related ones and um,
you know,
it would be a poor use of our limited funds to,
to,
to add a drop into that bucket,
um,
but most of the other things that we felt needed to be done have neglected.
So,
um,
let me think where I would even start.
Well,
okay.
One great example that we've been working on is not disease.
Atherosclerosis is of course the number one killer in the western world.
It's,
um,
it's the code of honor attacks and strokes and it's related because it's caused
by the lifelong accumulation of a particular type of damage.
And this guy to talk of damage is the accumulation of waste products in the
artery wall.
The wife that mattered to him the most is oxidized cholesterol.
Cholesterol itself is not a bad molecule.
People got this wrong a lot,
but glass right?
The vital molecule,
you don't want to remove your cholesterol,
you do want to have a remove the contamination cholesterol that accumulates a
low significant levels in the body oxidized restaurant in particular.
That is what poisons white blood cells that are in the artery wall and makes
them into what are called foam cells,
which are the first step in the creation of an atherosclerotic plaque.
And we'd like to stop that happening and we'd like to prevent atherosclerosis
for variety.
So the way we've done that is we've identified bacteria in the soil actually
that had Jane's and enzymes that are,
that allow them to break down oxidized cholesterol and we've identified these
bacteria and the drains and enzymes and we've introduced those genes into human
fell and fell culture.
And it works.
We have shown that these cells that have a engineered gene,
a much more protected,
that much more robust in the presence of a certain amount of this toxic oxidized
cholesterol than health data.
And of course we're moving forward to take that to,
um,
to,
uh,
other types of style into mice before we go into clinical trial.
That's the kind of thing that we're doing that earlier stage,
so it might take a bit longer.
This oxidized cholesterol.
Can this be eliminated with diet?
Absolutely.
You know the fundamental problem is that these molecules,
these oxidized cholesterol species,
they get into a white blood cells.
They get into a part of the cell called the lifers.
They poisoned the cell,
they inactivate the license,
and that means that the white blood cells can no longer do what they used to be
able to do it.
They can no longer process normal cholesterol.
No,
you can't do anything to the data.
That stuff is just there because the cells don't have any machinery to get rid
of it,
but are they a product of what we eat,
like product,
but it actually dental product,
so they happen just because the bound to happen,
but cholesterol comes from animal protein.
Is that a constant kind of we bring in cholesterol in our diet and we also
synthesize our own cholesterol and the liver and that's how it should be.
That cholesterol is doing a good job.
The problem is that oxidation is a chemical reaction that is going to happen in
the body,
whether you like it or not.
The fact is we are aerobic organisms.
We need to breathe,
we need to,
we need to inhale oxygen in order to keep going.
And breathing is really bad for you.
Breathing is bad for you.
Breathing is why we get free radicals,
but it's a bit nonnegotiable.
This is the thing.
So we've got to intervene in this process.
One step down the chain of events to get rid of the toxic products of breathing
rather than to get rid of breathing itself.
Breathing is bad for you.
That's a pretty straightforward statement.
And it's unequivocal.
Wow.
Um,
so when,
when they use like hyperbaric chambers,
oxygen rich environments to enhance healing,
is that extra band for you necessarily?
So of course breathing is also good for you if you don't breathe then yet at
least grade,
right?
So it's a trade off.
There are some aspects of branding than about for you.
And we need to fix that aspect.
And those aspects have zero to do with diet.
So this,
this,
well,
I wouldn't type of cholesterol,
so I feel really low on,
for example,
vitamin C or vitamin A,
then you are depleting your own body's ability to limit the toxicity of
breathing and therefore the breathing will be even more bad food that otherwise
would be.
So oxidants are crucial if you're going to bother breathing
to a point.
But it turns out that because breathing has been around a long time and
breathing,
breathing was invented about 2 billion years ago.
Um,
evolution has done what evolution tends to do.
It made the best of a bad job.
And therefore at this point,
some of the toxic byproducts of breathing free radical,
uh,
actually not just bad molecules that are also good,
they used by the body as signaling molecules.
So if we were to have a magic wand that we could wave and just get rid of all
the free radicals in the body,
that will be extremely bad.
You'd die at one.
What we have,
therefore,
a rather interesting balance that the body techs,
if you have too few antioxidants,
then that's bad news.
But if you have an abundance of antioxidants,
if you take megadoses of vitamin C or vitamin here,
for example,
doesn't really do much written.
It doesn't is because the body wants a certain amount of free radicals around so
it dials down the inherent,
the inbuilt antioxidant Mechan machinery and you end up basically where you
started.
So this bacteria that you're introducing to skin culture,
getting the bacteria themselves were introducing that one,
Jane from the back.
Terry one gene from an eminent,
integrating it into language,
artery tissue.
We are in cultures.
I thought.
Yes.
How far away do you believe you are to implementing this in an actual human
being
or?
Well,
clinical trials I think could be.
Could be 10 years away.
I think we were probably talking,
we'll probably talking a.
This is an intermediate one way might.
I would expect that we've got a 50 slash 50 chance of bringing this to the point
of being an approved therapy within maybe 15 years.
Now.
Me As a lay person,
standing on the outside looking at all this stuff,
I'm always very optimistic.
Oh yeah,
this is going to be great.
Within my lifetime,
to see some huge changes talking to you though,
it's not that I get less optimistic,
but I get more aware of the actual landscape itself and I started realizing,
well,
this this thing that we have that we're carrying around this body has an
indescribable number of operations that are going on simultaneously and there's.
There's there's reactions and counter reactions and all of these are completely
totally
understood,
so when you're.
You're talking about anti aging or life extension or any of these things,
you're talking about just a stupendous number of different processes that are
going on in the body that we're going to have to figure out and that is going to
take a very,
very long time and not one person is going to ever understand all of the
process.
Perfectly articulated why people who started the biology of aging Hud,
but about the mid 1980 to go to the point of absolute rejection of the idea that
what they even were working on was doing anything about aging.
Basically.
It had become very frowned upon even to talk about intervention and a ground
application,
for example.
Essentially,
because everyone understood,
oh my God,
the buddy,
it's a complicated.
We understand it so poorly.
It's never gonna happen,
so please.
So here's the thing that changed for in two steps.
First of all,
establish a workout and then the debt,
the debt,
the first thing that happened late 19,
88,
19,
98 with people started to discover simple ways to extend the longevity of some
certain laboratory organism,
initially worms and eventually my wife.
This was enormously exciting.
Those discoveries and they fall out from them,
still dominate the failed in people's eyes.
Uh,
the problem is it doesn't work for long lived organisms essentially because it's
all about the ability of the organism to respond to famine and short lived
organisms need to be able to respond more dramatically to Pharma.
And then long lived Wednesday.
So I'll go into more detail if you really well,
but that's the basics of it.
The one that did work was when I came along 15 years ago and talked about damage
repair.
Here's the reason why damage repair is so important.
It sidesteps a.
all of that complexity that you were talking about and all of our ignorance
about that complexity was it sidestep it because the damage that the body does
to itself throughout life as a side effect of its normal operation is only
harmful late in life.
The body is set up to tolerate a certain amount of that damage and the problem
only starts when the amount of damage exceeds the amount that I set up to
tolerate.
So that means that until that point,
the damage is not participating in this massively complex network of processes
that we call metabolism.
It's just accumulating as a,
uh,
an inert byproduct.
It's only by mass action after it becomes a enormously abundant in late life
that it becomes part of metabolism,
a gap that's hugely important.
It means that if we go in and target the damage,
one who's not participating in metabolism,
we have a much better chance of doing so appreciable side of that than we would
if we were going in and trying to manipulate metabolism itself.
Which abl within itself,
yeah,
and crazy insane network of Spaghetti code that not got any comments,
so to speak.
And you try to do anything to it to stop it doing the thing.
You don't want it to do the creation of damage.
You're going to have unintended consequences that do more harm than good,
but if you don't do that,
if you instead of the damage itself was is outside of that network of metabolism
than he'd done had that problem in the same way.
Is there any focus on concentrating on the potential of.
You were saying that the body has a very good ability to deal with all this
damage at a young age and as you get older it becomes less and less able to
blend the real solution,
be catching it early.
Finding people that are very young and implementing these strategies on them.
Not really because the only reason why an older person who's less able to cope
with the it,
it's because the older person has more damage occurring.
Moreover around why is that?
Because it had longer to accumulate and me going away,
so young person doesn't have much damage.
It doesn't really make sense for someone in their twenties.
Even 30,
let's look for 20,
30,
40 years from now when they therapies actually exist,
would it make sense for a 20 year old to actually a of the therapist?
Probably not because that's going to be at least another 20 or 30 years before
they're going to suffer any actual serious functional decline as a result of
this damage and during that time the therapy,
they're going to get better by more convenient and more comprehensive and
thorough.
The tradeoff is to wait for the therapist to be improved.
Well,
that's not necessarily what I was getting at.
What I was getting at.
You were saying that over time that damage accumulates to the point where your
body can no longer process the damage anymore.
What would it be?
More advantageous to catch it before it accumulates to deal with the issues
before they become substantial?
Well,
but what fence is,
we're going in and saying,
let's not take 20 year old,
but yes,
like 40 or 50 year old,
eight year old,
not 80 year olds.
You're fucked if you're 80 already fucked you just for now that it's harder.
Let me go into that a little bit more data.
If you take someone who's let's say 50,
that all the natives defense therapy,
the damage repair therapy that reduce their level of damage to a white world
back when they were 20 or 30 years ago,
and of course bundling periodically.
No,
if the damage has already got the point where it caused disease and disability
to image.
Let's say someone who's typically it,
they've gone downhill quite a lot.
Then these therapies are still going to be very useful,
but they're going to be useful in a slightly different way.
They're going to be useful when used in combination with traditional geriatric
therapy.
The kind that currently we have today.
Remember what I said earlier,
that the geriatric therapies today don't work and they never will work.
Basically because they're attacking the symptoms.
They are kind of laboring under the apprehension that the diseases of old age or
like infections.
Well that means is that basically they hacking away at something that is
becoming harder and harder to hack away at because it's cause it namely the
damage from me throughout life.
It's continuing to accumulate,
so if you think about what that means,
if we were able to go in and actually repair the damage,
then we would be in,
if you like,
potentiating the geriatric therapists,
we will allow the geriatric therapist to actually work and it may end up being
that we need to do that,
that if someone's in there,
it was going downhill and we only fix the damage that got them that way.
That won't be enough because the diseases,
the pathology is,
we'll have a lot of their own at that point.
We made to go in at two levels at the same time.
What are these geriatric therapists that I've just been,
I've just been like,
you know,
um,
uh,
injecting dopamine for Parkinson's disease for example.
Basically,
you know,
short term benefit,
mild benefit,
a reason.
It's basically the problem is getting worse.
The cell to continuing to die,
you're going to need more and more drug.
Many become more and more resistant to,
for me,
it's being supplied in the wrong schedule anywhere at the wrong times because
you can own it because just took it to the nature of delivery.
You can only deliver it in a Boliss,
uh,
you know,
these things are all ways in which such therapies cannot be perfect.
Whereas if we were to put the cells back to repair the originating damage,
then any other things downstream that had gone wrong in the rest of the brain
would be treatable by other therapies,
by more traditional therapies in a much more effective way.
And they can now one of their methods or you're looking into for repairing
damage other than introducing this bacteria to.
Okay.
So that's.
So that's the second one I mentioned the first run,
but wherever was just stem cell therapy,
right?
Uh,
let's take another one.
Let's take um,
the immune system.
So the immune system is a classic example of the problem of what I call death
resistant cells.
That means cells with that rather than having too few of them in Parkinson's
disease,
you have too many of them.
And in particularly,
you have too many because they're not dying when they're supposed to.
People don't often think in terms of the idea that felt that there could be any
cells that should die,
but the immune system is a great example of that where when you get an
infection,
finances I have now,
in fact,
you have a very small population of white blood cells that divide like crazy to
get to a big enough population to attack and eliminate the infection.
After that happened,
that almost all of them die again to leave written basically for a completely
different subset to divide like crazy.
Next time you get a different infection.
Turns out that in old age,
that whole cycle of division and death,
uh,
basically goes wrong and you end up with a lot of cells that divide like crazy
to attack an infection.
Then when the things got away,
they don't die again.
And they're getting in the way they inhibited the proliferation of other cells.
So what do we want to do about that?
Well,
there are various options out there,
but we think that we need to go for the juggler of this.
We need to do something that's very decisive and so we're looking at a method
that's called suicide gene therapy.
Well now that sounds pretty crazy,
doesn't it?
But it turns out that it's actually much less crazy than the name implies.
So it's like gene therapy has been a routine technique in the lab,
a Doosan mice,
for example,
for quite a long time.
Essentially what it is is you introduce a gene into cells that produce the toxic
protein when the protein is produced,
the cell dies,
but you arrange this so that the protein is only produced when the cell gets
into a particular state that you don't want to do.
At that point,
I'm relatively routine idea.
The,
what we would like to do is to make it work for humans.
And the problem there is you've got to make it safe.
Of course.
Now,
gene therapy in general is a very tricky concept to make safe and that it some
ups and downs over the past 20 years at least.
But the um,
got into service,
I didn't therapy had additional difficulties.
You really don't want this go this Jane talks that where's the toxic protein?
Just killing cells randomly when it shouldn't be.
So we're working on new,
more elaborate ways to put multiple lines of defense against that problem.
How many different people do you guys employ that you have working on all these
various methods?
Kind of.
Depends on what you mean by employed because we have some people that way fund
through university labs,
but taking the broader definition of everyone who relied on us for that salary,
I think throughout that at this point.
And do you,
do you personally oversee all these various projects or do you other the chief
science officer?
I oversee the project and the fence of.
Yes,
I would say the decision making process of prioritizing projects,
deciding which new projects to do,
deciding how about I was going to regularly with the professors and other lab
heads that are responsible for the project.
So yeah,
that's what I did in addition to,
of course also bang the chief outreach reserve and the chief wizard.
I mean,
not mean everyone notices you,
you're talking about life extension.
Then you have a sorceress beard.
This is by that day I told my last float by.
Well,
I feel bad for the ethic.
That's right.
Then he asked the my wife campaigns after we met for a long time.
We met 25 years ago now and it took her five years to persuade me to grow there,
but eventually I tried to give it a go and I was as surprised as anybody when it
came out like this.
That's interesting because that's kind of your calling card I suppose it has
become.
So
are you satisfied by this research?
Is this is a stimulating to you?
Is this something that you truly enjoying this process?
Well,
I always have an ambivalence.
On the one hand,
yes,
I'm extremely gratified that it's going so well from a personal perspective of
if I'm proud that I've been able to make a significant difference,
but at the same time all of that,
it always enormously to by the knowledge that the still a lot of people dying
out that,
that this is not going to fly.
So I talked about our budget before,
I felt like,
you know,
we have about $5 million a year that we spend.
That's an incredibly small amount for the thing that producers most of the
world's suffering.
Right?
Wow.
What the Hell's going on there?
And that's why I spend more of my time trying to raise money than I do actually
overseeing the thought I have to the dilemma.
Right.
Well that's right.
I mean even if it was a third one more zero to that budget,
if we had like $50,000,000 or $100,000,000,000 a year spend,
we'd probably be going three times faster,
three times faster and that would save the most insane number of lie.
That's the thing that really gets me out of bed in the morning.
Do you have the ear of politicians?
Do you have the ear of,
of of people that are in charge of the universities that will listen to you and
perhaps allocate more money your way.
It's a very complicated network of conversations that needs to happen.
The difficulty with politicians,
of course there's the politicians ultimately have one single God I live,
which is to get reelected as the public policy tends to follow public opinion
rather than leading edge.
So it's more important to me to appeal to public opinion and try to educate
people and right at the quality of debate,
that's why they said that interviews like this apart from anything else.
Um,
then of course there's other people,
you know,
this wealthy individuals trying to,
I try to,
I try to meet as many of those.
I can generally get them to understand what's going on.
The fact that we're a five,
zero,
one c,
three public charity obviously does help.
It means that anyone can give us money in a tax efficient manner,
but no,
we've just got to get more of that money in the door.
Do you have kickstarter?
Go Fund me.
Any of those accounts?
We have done a certain amount of crowd funding,
but ultimately must,
well,
pretty much all of the crowd funding a,
that can be taken a really difficult to reconcile with what we do essentially.
Because if you're looking for small amounts,
fine,
but we're looking for relatively large amount of United States seven digit,
um,
project for those things.
It's really got to appeal to the imagination what the specific achievement is
going to be a,
with early stage.
It's really hard to explain that in terms that really gripped paypal.
So it's not really worked all that well for us.
What we were describing before that pharmaceutical companies sort of hedging
their bets,
waiting on the sidelines for something to be worth betting on.
Boy,
I'd like to change that if we can,
whatever impact we can have on it and this podcast gets millions and millions of
downloads and I'm sure we'll have some effect on it,
but I would like to,
you know,
whatever you need,
do you need things tweeted for you and posted on the bottom.
This is fascinating stuff to me.
I'm obviously because I have zero research background,
no medical science background.
So to me it's like when I get a chance to talk to someone like you,
it's like a window into this world that I only a ordinarily get through articles
and papers.
I think it's,
um,
it's,
it's massively important.
It's also,
as I discussed before,
as I said before,
I think it's a fundamental part of human nature.
We want to improve everything and your health and your,
your ability to enjoy this time is huge and if you could extend that,
you,
you have the potential to be a better person.
I think I'm a better person now than I was 10 years ago.
I think I'd be even better if I could get another 100 and you know,
I think we could do some real change and I think a lot of that real change
could,
you know,
there's that issue.
Like why worry about this are fundamental problems are the toxification of the
environment,
blah,
blah.
I think we could put more emphasis on that if we could have some of the
brilliant people that we have a live today live longer
back in 2006.
When I spoke at Ted,
actually I made that whole comfort,
the centerpiece of my talk.
I said basically zero visionaries.
You like aiming high.
This could be the critical feature of this.
Even independently of the in inherent humanitarian value of defeating aging,
aging is the thing that has ground up doubt over the history of civilization,
the thing that has made us know that we are at the mercy of nature.
If we can bring that truly under control,
then this will empower us.
It will make us feel really much more confident that we can address the other
really hard problems,
whether it's climate change,
you know,
world peace,
whatever it might be.
The guys who run the global 20 slash 45 initiative,
the,
uh,
the idea that,
there'll be some sort of technological answer to this question.
Are they supportive of the biological ideas as well as their cooperation between
these two groups?
Sure,
yeah.
There's always a spectrum of opinion with regard to desirability and feasibility
of the things.
But absolutely,
you know,
everyone knows that we're on the same side.
We're not in favor of getting fit.
You are truly a mad scientist.
I know you're tired and I know you,
you're way past your bedtime when it comes to the UK.
So I really appreciate you being here and for for folks at home,
what's the best way to contact you?
What's the best way to send money?
What's the best way to reach out?
But that's why I have to go to sense.org.
That's [inaudible]
dot org.
Just go there.
It had all the information about what we do,
about what we'd like to do about what we have done.
It got all the information you could imagine about why this is important.
It's got a nice way to contact us with any method you'd like and of course with
a nice big friendly donate button.
Anytime you're in town,
please be more than happy to promote anything you've got going on.
Any speech,
speeches you're doing,
any anything you're promoting,
please don't hesitate to ask.
I'd be more than happy to help.
Well,
you're extremely conscious.
I thank you for having me on the show.
I'm absolutely sure that being on the show will make a difference in and of
itself and the more that you can do to help the real band,
the more live you will.
Five.
Wow.
I hope you're right.
You're.
You're really impressive individual.
I really,
really appreciate you taking your time.
Aubrey de grey.
Ladies and gentlemen,
you can you respond to your twitter.
Do you ever go there and you look at it a little bit?
Check it out.
Don't send them anything rude.
Fucking freaks.
Alright.
Thank you very much,
brother.
I really,
really appreciate it.
I really.
Great Ladies,
gentlemen.
Oh,
that was fun.